hello everyone I'm Alicia Malone this is
Fandango indie movie guide and I've got
some great smaller films to put on your
radar starting with one of the best of
the year tis the season awards season
check out Manchester by the sea I have
anything big to say I'm something just I
know you've been around and I thought
just be good better settle then it seems
like he's doing pretty good huh
considering I think he is yeah
Manchester by the seas one of those
movies that has a big reveal and it's
the kind of reveal you don't want to
know going in and it's the kind of
reveal that will stay with you for a
long time basically it's about a guy
who's played by Casey Affleck his
brother dies at the start of the film
and he has to go back home
face some demons in order to be a
guardian for his nephew and what those
demons are are revealed so slowly and
masterfully by director Kenneth Lonnegan
the way he flashes backwards and
forwards in time allowing the audience
to put the pieces together it is like a
jigsaw puzzle of heartbreak and that
heartbreak is devastating
putting awards watch on this one for
Casey Affleck for Michelle Williams who
plays his ex-wife and for the film in
general do not miss Manchester by the
same I'm gonna bother you know just sit
there until you calm down or I don't
calming it would you please just go away
you know
now to another fave nocturnal animals
directed by Tom Ford yep
the designer Tom Ford you didn't sleep
again did you you know me I never sleep
my ex-husband used to call me a
nocturnal animal this is Tom Ford's
second feature film and this is why I'm
mad at him he is so damn talented it is
not fair I mean his clothes are lovely
and very popular his first movie a
single man was practically in
masterpiece and now he's gone invested
himself is that actually saying I don't
know but he's done even better with
nocturnal animal where he seamlessly
weaves together three different story
lines with incredible impeccable style
and a fantastic cast good evening you
know you're supposed to stop when
there's an accident right yeah and why
don't you stop there and don't worry I
won't spoil anything with this movie
either because this was also a great
surprise Amy Adams plays a woman whose
ex-husband played by my future husband
Jake Gyllenhaal sent her a manuscript of
his new book it seems to be about her
and it gets very dark and twisted this
is kind of like Alfred Hitchcock meets
David Lynch meets Sam Peckinpah meets
Nicolas Winding roughen Awards watch on
this one as a possible picture
nomination not entirely sure but I got
to sit down with my future husband Jake
Gyllenhaal and Amy Adams who was very
kind and in on the joke to talk a little
bit about nocturnal animals have a look
he even I was really impressed with how
what a skillful hand he approached this
film any director forget that he's a
designer any director who's able to
segue between present and past and you
know the reality and fiction the way he
did I saw it at Toronto I have not been
able to stop thinking about it not just
because it stars Jake Gyllenhaal future
husband but just cuz there's some great
moments in there so such a supportive
and loving spouse I'm right there I see
all his films I'm always like can I
interview here should I leave I feel
like I'm like like block and be my
wingwoman oh I was gonna be nice about
it
Jake when you first read the script was
there a moment that really stuck with
you the the whole situation in the
desert is really striking and I think
that that's what undoes the story and
then in a weird way it creates tension
throughout the whole thing so you have
this like sort of steamroller attention
until the very end because of that event
and that event is so shocking and I
remember reading and being like so tense
now to those two films about improv
comedy two very different films but both
you can watch at home
the first is Asperger's R Us a
documentary produced by the Duplass
brothers directed by Alex Lehmann who
also directed blue J which I spoke about
a couple of episodes ago on this show
this one is about an improv comedy
troupe made up of people on the autism
spectrum and the documentary follows
them as they prepare for their last
national tour it's funny it's sweet it
helps you understand a little bit more
about the world of someone who is on the
spectrum and I love the cast of
real-life characters that they managed
to capture in this movie these guys are
my best friends I don't really have
anything
then there's don't think twice a great
little indie comedy directed by Mike
Birbiglia five minutes guys please tell
me when I'm racist yeah his first movie
was about stand-up comedy this one is
about improv comedy it's about an improv
comedy troupe who's a very tight-knit
group until one of them becomes famous
it's got themes of jealousy of
competitiveness of despair about your
dreams never coming true even if you're
not into improv comedy
you can definitely relate to one of
these things I know I can and it's got a
great cast as well with keegan-michael
key and Gillian Jacobs recapping in
theaters you can watch Manchester by the
sea or nocturnal animals and at home
check out Asperger's r us or don't think
twice so because I keep mentioning my
favorite films of the year I thought I
should keep some kind of leaderboard so
I've decided to do my top five of the
year so far out of the movies that are
in theaters not the ones that I've
managed to have a sneak peek of at film
festivals and I know this suit looks
like it's those tops so far but that's
actually supposed to be five I'm just
terrible at rising number one moon light
number two Manchester by the sea number
three arrival number four nocturnal
animals and number five the handmaiden
check out these films if you haven't
already and that's it for me for this
episode of Fandango indie movie Guide
let me know below what did some of your
favorite Indies of the year or foreign
films or interesting movies I love to
hear from you guys you can always follow
me anytime at Alicia Malone I'll see you
soon wait